ciao a tutti oggi a box di due scavo del
mistery box box uno da 15 euro e una da
50 euro
spero che hanno tormentato per decidere
chi aprire la mente di postel atene non
si mangia tutto questo cosa si stia
dentro le ho comprate su essi non è
l'idea di cosa si stia dentro questo
penso che sia un tema un po kawaii dello
speaker
questo è un po carta da zucchero
giocatore aspetta allora se volete
vedere andrea boxing e thai boxe
lasciate pure un bel laica questo video
e se arriva di simile letto dobbiamo
farne un altro
scrivete sicure che tipo di vista i
nostri volete vedere che tema cibo ad
esempio non funziona mente di qualcuno
dovrebbe venire quindi dice volevo anche
ringraziarvi per tutti nel senso
eastwood che mi avete scritto su
instagram è su youtube riguarda la morte
di un tempo purtroppo
grazie mille davvero stiamo bene
una grandissima famiglia ho sentito
tanto il nostro affetto e degli ingressi
tantissimo piano piano realizzando che a
sette anni ho fatto che non ci sarà più
però cerco di non pensarci come ora
facciamo carta forbice sasso iniziamo da
questa piccolina e vediamo chi da un box
accanto colpisce già fatto che aspetta
si fa così carthago di centa se poi non
butti ok non fai prima dopo ok ma non me
ne farò uno due tre una frase che ho
sempre ok 123 da jano di che io per
questo suo amore quella nostra
allora abbiamo mai staccata da quincy
euro spero che si sia distinto nello
smalto non penso che ci saranno molte
cose essendo da un pensiero di john
scegliendo allora abbiamo penna a furbo
di gatto tra l'altro sembra proprio
bimbo con la faccina grigio
[Musica]
astori ancora ed è una penna che carino
fuori abbiamo abbiamo avuto 3
non so se avete mai visto che avete mai
visto toto roma è un cartone bellissimo
di miyazaki
se non l'avete mai visto guardato lo
stupendo e tutto ed è un portamonete
troppo chiara nettamente imposta da
quindi insieme lo smoke atenei gatto
bravi e un gattone ciccioli e un vettore
ciccione
[Musica]
[Applauso]
i gatti quindi questi a famiglia
scrivete del suo miglior gare anche lo
stesso colore
io poi hello kitty questo non so chi sia
un gatto l'edizione che penso che sia
proprio questo pero questo e si è così
chiamava gatto come si chiamavano per
dolo piccola scrivete nei commenti come
si chiama to guardavo da piccola il
gatto che li portava tante cose il
bambino è recato magico mondo ride molto
ma d'ora in poi l'utente prosa che ci
sono 78 lo è un conato personal sito
però libro una pena di torno più carino
se totolo sopra è uno stecchino questo
dell'altro sembra l'altro dalla penna
quasi ha scritto totò e c'è un'altra
pena troppo carina si spiega con un
gattone okcom minuto gli occhi per le
amanti dei gatti troppo bella questa
forza si chiama fruttero poi vediamo un
po non so come si chiami questo
personaggio sembra giapponese lo stesso
[Musica]
ci sono tantissimi stick di questo
personaggio che non capisco se è un cane
o ditemi voi se quando vuoi cercare un
coniglio se conoscete come si chiama di
bambina c'è una bambina che scrive nel
fumetto si quindi pratica è come se
scrivesse nel caso che poi voi andrete a
scrivere nel post it che correndo anche
questo giapponese pensa a te ma chiediti
cosa poco uscito in condizione di tanti
adesivi di un quello fisso un
coniglietto sezione che carini anche
giusto dove li posso attaccare tutti
perché dice il cane
nel frattempo che michele costruisce
troviamo impresso io costruisco concia
di casa ci sono due gusci tapes quindi
adesivi colorati verde e il roda piccoli
riva carini poi altri due adesivi di
altre due personaggi che però non
conosco una paperella e ginger freddo
forse poi se un astuccio un astuccio con
un orsetto con scritto non è lei che
carino io vi ricordate magozzi la forma
tipo un tamagotchi di carta apriamo lo
attendiamo anche questi ora pratica qua
ci sono questi cosi ma so che si
osservano sono di plastica sottile ma
non sono adesivi
scrivetemi pure di commenti secondo voi
servono o cari signori notte il cane
michele alì che senza che si sta
distruggendo
[Musica]
per tutto questo tempo quello che era
successo con lo stesso voto diamo a
questa messa tipo troppe 11 euro insieme
lo assistiamo di rimandare anche perché
cosa va avanti pop attese frega se
questo troppo piccoli per iscriversi
solo quello che per decorare per andrea
possano andar bene poi con sé che questo
xvi sembra che arrivino dal giappone
quindi che potrei di dianetics abbiamo
[Musica]
dambel 88 sì io non ammetto
vorrei invece che voto date a questa
vita in box da 1 a 10
scrivetelo nei commenti le scriventi si
pone la cosa più carina che abbiamo
trovato qua secondo me questo bertone
ciccione una penna comitato che mi
ricorda pippo perché si aspetta qui in
pietre ciccione siete contenti di vivere
il teramo si va dai mentale spera di
trovare scritto anche qua ma non certo
perché no se lo spazio per questo pare
nostralino tutto fuori come l'on
apri in faccia sono già quasi
intravedere qualcosa che compone di con
voi perché quando invece di mettere gli
esseri umani allora assieme a lettera
giuste
questi sono i suoi sì c'è scritto questi
sono i tuoi sette giorni di sorprese il
misseri boxes che hai comprato questa
scatola che è stato fatto un sessioni di
reiki di guarigione brake è enorme
tecnica giapponese per ridurre lo stress
è il rilassamento che promuove anche il
lavori scatola scusa sta traducendo in
tempo reale dall'inglese per quello
parlo in questa scatola troverai una 20
st è una pietra spirituale protettiva e
purificati va che pulisce l'energia di
una persona riguarda influenze negative
e crea un uno scudo protettivo di luce
spirituale attorno il corpo cerca di
portare con te tutto il tempo
ok quindi ma neanche chi fa queste box
sia la persona un po spirituale dentro
una scatola troverai 7 regali per sette
giorni della settimana
puoi aprire un recava giorno iniziando
con quello col numero 1 all'inizio puoi
andare avanti ha finora
speriamo davvero che ti piacerà perché
tutti i regali e che ti porterà un po di
sole nella tua vita
quindi in teoria in questa scatola
bisogna per il regalo al giorno così per
una settimana sia un regalo al giorno no
ancora ovviamente andremo fermo tutto
oggi perché sennò frey aspettare troppo
tempo che c'è allora per prima cosa c'è
una busta però il fine non ho chiesto il
numero uno ma ho visto tante tante cose
che si possa normalizzare
non ci credo questo box mi piace allora
sempre chiamato la scatola permette
spirituale che ha capito che se la
mangione allora quali se apri ora c'è
una clip con la buia finché carina e
questo immagino che sia il primo la
prima cosa da aprile lo facesse qualcosa
di strano
affermazioni positive e allora questa
persona una persona molto positiva per
ci tiene al al benessere delle persone
c'è un foglio intero con se volete
fatelo screenshot aspetto che lo metto
dritto
se volete fatelo screenshot se capite
l'inglese magari che può servire anche
per voi c'è scritto affermazioni
positive ce ne sono 40
leggiamone qualcuno non c'è nessuno
meglio di me stesso
beh senza paura a duettare c'è niente di
meglio che essere me stesso che è un
problema anche diverse
la felicità è mia il mio corpo può
guarire completamente
amo me stesse sono perfettamente sana
lei sia qualcun altro
detto questo qui mi sento meglio anche
il giorno la mia mente libera aperta
tutto sono io il capo della mia vita mi
merito solo cose buone
e vabbè poi hamilton ma non è che già
stato testimone
ok invece grazie allora c'è un'altra un
altro foglietto spirituale dice che le
affermazioni possono essere un metodo
molto positivo per cambiare il tuo modo
di essere
va beh insomma ecco bravo andiamo a
mangiare cose così dire parliamo
parliamo però noi dobbiamo ignorare
stiamo scherzando per il red ral
credo anche in queste cose penso che
bisogna essere positivi soprattutto
verso se stessi verso la vita
però è anche normale sentirsi giù e non
stare sempre al massimo superfici e
normale essere umani però bisogna anche
affrontare la vita con positività
accettare se stessi non paragonarsi agli
altri è essere felici di quello che sia
concordo comunque con questo mercato è
comunque un messaggio positivo vediamo
nuvole all'altra lettera allora festa è
scritta a mano che comunque non c'è
scritto grazie mille per aver ordinato
questa scatta questa scatola
spero che metteranno subito sul tuo viso
e se lo fa se ci fa sorridere
potresti darsi tuo feedback significa
molto per noi non l'abbia parma via vai
è impossibile allora ci andiamo una
penna una ben dietro la notizia non sia
quella di carta
aspetta serata si apre guarda questi m e
una cannuccia con il pro capite per bene
sei una cartuccia non di plastica di
carta cambio open toe tre realtà
l'elicottero rosa poi che se abbiamo poi
qui mi sa che ci abbiamo la pietra del
18 la meta che ricarica su di energia
positiva che siamo allora ecco qua la
pietra dell'ametista forse la conoscete
viola e bianca molto carina questa è la
metto sul mio desk vediamo se mi porta
fortuna acqua e l'abbiamo una farfalla
ma ora una matita farfalla in questi
primi ciak in the black titolo unicredit
a e poi ci abbiamo anche spies suite che
ti piace tanto a questo e senza caffeina
si gioca a stoppare stanotte prima di
andare a dormire
questo è un po un po
sono più ma che ritorna e allora no
dell'impotenza su 11 sono 474 no dal
numero uno ok che bello sono tutti in
pochi casi come se fossero dei regali
personalizzati dai ha previsto calo vero
ma domani si scusa ma l'ho visto questo
16 una nota personalizzata anche un wow
ho scritto un po di ispirazione spero
che ti piaccia allora c'è scritto sì più
unicorno come troppo attivo come trovare
te stesso guardate i colori come trovato
per te stesso no il tempo ovvero vero
nel tempo in colori di questo ho scritto
sono fighissimi e poi qua dietro c'è un
unicorno
vediamo di cosa parla questo video libro
allora in pratica ci sono delle
descrizioni di unicorni il più
affermazioni positive e molto colorato
molto carino penso che sia l'ideale
anche per chi magari sta imparando
l'inglese che sembra abbastanza semplice
da reggere molto carino quindi questo è
il numero uno spezia
però è il cibo certi e così non fatico a
che c'è scritto una bomba da bagno alla
fragola canestro sembra un cupcake e
quindi entro cerchiamo tutti questi
stessi misero per farlo il club questa
basta bond bel bagno
diciamoci tutto pancino bandai ha la
stoffa c'è altro di nora de canio nichi
non mettete tipo 3 beta 3 è che lo stato
non solo benevolo scosso www questo ho
già capito che cos'è una specchietto e
figlia per truccarsi adoriamo look o più
diffusa
guardate quanto sei bella 47 ben quattro
ribelli sciiti sono vergine potevi dei
beni da venti forse no comunque questo
specchietto dov'è oggi così questo
riguarda nove sono vitale non voterò
quattro li faccio vedere il pack e
zucchero
l'italia non può vedere niente
questo suo viaggio è molto carino rosa
sembra un uovo di pasqua
si forma così pesante
[Musica]
kat
un unicorno guardate qua il manico del
tipo la cosa dell'unicorno multicolor le
stelline sulle rotte e vede scontrarsi
con le cose a un incrocio notte c'era
messaggio un altro con phon assieme
perché fa allora soffitto todi che la
tua tazza di tè ed è camomilla e manu
canone e senza caffeina in questione ad
ora perché le forze prima di andare a
dormire troppo carine ma non voglio
aiutare la molto carino ma se c'è un
problema perché vedo il numero 5 non c'è
il pacchetto attaccato 5 credo che tutto
quello che non era chiara vedrei più
cavi nel pacchetto oggi lingue
retrospezione atene lo spigolo sulle
vada hai avuto allora devono 5 braille
[Musica]
aiuto per te introduce per il giorno
della cura di se stessi quindi è un quiz
è uno scrub
per il corpo al kiwi al kiwi non ho mai
avuto niente al kiwi quindi sarà
interessante questo può essere il giusto
e ci vorrà un altro devono farlo vedere
ma come si fa a fare gli han boxing con
vitale prende bene che un simbolo parla
di nozze senza neanche aspettare allora
cui abbiamo un bellissimo pacchetto a
forma di caramella e molto dell'eni
facile nemmeno l'idea di trascrizione
abbiamo a meno uno ius descritto per
tenere due piedi caldi e comodi
allora ci sono delle calze con i donut è
scritto dona che non ti preoccupare sono
enormi tipo questa nota e probabilmente
che comunque sono bellissimi produrre
tenendo sarò sicuramente numero assente
qui si passa al cibo
l'ultimo
divertendosi ritorni che bello guardate
che bello alla carta con gli unicorni le
farfalle luminose cammino realtà private
l'ho fatta oleografica ma volevo
oleografia olio
beh allora ho capito che la prossima
volta devo ordinare una miss the box di
cibo
sì sì casaccio sapere soldi ma non so
nemmeno se esistono i duke corrida
allora allora spero che ti sarà utile
questo è un kit un kit per la manicure
con tagliamo un ghiere di metta insomma
queste cose tutto fosse nervosa
[Applauso]
ciao i poteri sopra ma che quegli
elicotteri
adesso passiamo a tutti chiesto che
stava questo che non siete conosciuti
dai due cose alte così facciamo le cose
come si deve
abbiamo un palloncino extra per chi
volesse ormai poi una una profumatissima
una profumatissima grande alla rosa che
profuma di niente e noi abbiamo altre 13
roma e poi finanziate di norma da
masticare riguarda siccome sono gentile
tenera calo al 32 un aprendo sopra
abbiamo un altro hotel
questo è il bianco al mirtillo alle
terre flowers che non so come l'inter
italiano vede un altro tel
e poi guarda non dire che noi siamo ti
regalo un diamante bellissimo
dovete lo dobbiamo per reply male io
invece mi prendo questa cioccolata che
[Musica]
c'è scritto gran che ecco qua è la buona
tampone allora o net offre il km he una
cioccolata vegana infatti è lampone
coccola è il cioccolato fondente quindi
senza latte perché abbiamo dei
torroncini all arancio e poi intorno al
chino al limone interessante per i
mandanti in fase ii c'è qualcosa tutto
sopra limits on non lo so furono
confermate allora sono o dietro la piuma
primo intanto si prende una bella
mangiata
no è buonissimo
ma è al mondo come insegnano tipo globe
un pieno di cioccolato fuori come può
in questo modo che vuole ben altro si
legga questo buonissimo punto qualcosa
comunque se mi volete mandare dalle box
di cibo a scattare dal 1
no problema per non datemi quello delle
bozze di cibo no sto scherzando
ovviamente questo è il buonissimo è
buonissimo sa di co.co.pro il cioccolato
fondente buono perché proprio intenso
monista la magia che consegnano la magia
stanotte poi cioccolato sparirà bisogno
di tutti è la cosa che mi è piaciuta di
più è questa tassa è più penda veramente
bellissima la cosa che mi è piaciuto
meno e penso questo kit di unghie è
questo specchietto sono forma così così
ho apprezzato un capo che abbia messo
delle cosè tra come della camera
profumate it e le tisane che io adoro
abbiamo sempre
[Musica]
il cioccolato che su topi carità più di
20 giri e là senza cintura di socrates
che cosa è piaciuto di più 18 piani per
scattare anticipo guardiamo il cibo
bella tazza sicuramente carina ad un
ritorno anche la bat bomb non dà l'idea
di non provare ancora però hip hop e non
indosserebbe non vedere tu quella che
parla perché ha una lunghezza che voglio
vederti a mente la scatola era 50 euro
il totale ma erano le spedizioni che
erano molto care perché viene
dall'inghilterra infatti la scatola
costava 30 euro le spedizioni costante
ormai intorno ai mesi diciamo qualcosa
quindi il totale insomma di questo
dovrebbe essere l'ente euro che non è
niente male perché un prodotto troppo
siena cioè non lo è
voi che potevate questa box da 1 a 10
noi che voto gli diamo il permesso per
il fatto che comunque era costosa sono
felice delle cose che c'erano dentro
anche il fatto che questa ragazza è una
donna
abbia messo così tanta paura è qui alla
fine all'interno vedi non c'era tutta la
descrizione le cose qui attacca già
speso un po di tempo tutti i bigliettini
personalizzati non è stato prima data
molta cura comunque è anche molte delle
sorpresine molti extra
quindi sì direi un sette e mezzo forse
anche di più lo stesso euro st 5 otto e
mezzo che per 15 euro c'erano un bel pò
di fondo che anche loro però poi
ovviamente questo è il più bello però
stiamo considerando il fatto che
costasse di più i temi vuoi quando mi è
piaciuto di più di questa box scommetto
che è costato sto mi è piaciuto un sacco
muovere se non vi piacciono gli ricordi
no
ditemi cosa mi è piaciuto di più di
questo box e cosa mi è piaciuto bene e
noi vi lasciamo equa quattro cartellini
superati coniato proprio ha detto se
pubblica e forse è meglio che stiano
creando il panico 4 cardellino di
pubblicare per vedere i nostri altri
video video divertenti
charlene sostiene cliccate su quella che
preferite buona visione